das erste um Boris Pistorius zu hören
haben wir intensiv und darum bemüht und
konnten
nachdem ich gestern offiziell zum
Verteidigungsminister ernannt worden bin
bin ich heute also nach etwas mehr als
24 Stunden hier eingetroffen
und hatte muss wirklich sagen dass große
Vergnügen in dieser wirklich unglaublich
bauen eindruckenden Gemeinschaft von
Nation zu Unterstützung der Ukraine in
dem Krieg gegen Russland
hier an teilnehmen zu können dank US ich
habe der USA den USA ausdrücklich dafür
zu danken für die erneute Ausrichtung
dieses Formats hier in Ramstein in der
Pfalz
die Situation in der Ukraine ist weiter
außerordentlich dramatisch gerade jetzt
im Winter das können wir jeden Tag
beobachten die russischen Luftangriffe
die gegen die Ukraine erhalten an und
führen zu fürchterlichen Schäden und
fürchterlichen Verlusten und wir müssen
davon ausgehen dass sie noch Monate
weitergehen
Kriegsverlauf selbst der
Kriegsverbrechen die humanitäre
Situation fordern uns gerade zu auf
unverändert und umfangreich mit
Ausrüstung und Waffen zu unterstützen
und dieses commitment habe ich gerade
auch in der großen Runde noch einmal
sehr deutlich gesagt Deutschland wird
nicht aufhören damit Deutschland wird
nicht nachlassen die Ukraine zu
unterstützen und es geht darum
Perspektiven aufzuzeigen natürlich
aufzuzeigen um die russische Aggression
möglichst rasch zu beenden
das Ziel muss sein
dass Engagement von uns allen von mehr
als 50 Staaten die heute vertreten sind
muss am konkreten Bedarf der Ukraine
ausgerichtet sein aktuell bereitet
Deutschland deshalb die Lieferung von
bis zu 40 Mardern Schützenpanzern
Mardern vor
US-amerikanische Panzer sind ebenfalls
in der Lieferung vorgesehen eine
ähnliche Anzahl ist in der Lieferung es
gibt eine enge Abstimmung in dieser
Frage mit allen Alliierten die hier
lieferfähig und lieferwillig sind es
gibt einen synchronisiertes vorgehen und
darauf legen das ist in den Runden auch
sehr deutlich geworden alle gemeinsam
großen Wert
ein Punkt ist besonders hervorgehoben
werden worden in allen Gesprächen bis
jetzt Priorität Nummer eins ist
Luftverteidigung Luftverteidigung
Luftverteidigung insbesondere auch mit
Blick auf Munition deswegen wird das
auch den obersten Vorrang die obersten
Rang einnehmen müssen wir werden
unsererseits zur Stärkung der
Luftverteidigung eine feuereinheit des
flugabwehrraketensystem Patrick in die
Ukraine liefern auch diese zeitlich mit
unseren us-partnern abgestimmt außerdem
werden wir weitere sieben Flak Gepard
Panzer aus industriebeständen im Januar
ist Februar 23 folgen lassen sodass dann
insgesamt 37 Gepard Panzer aus
Deutschland in der Ukraine im Einsatz
sind im kommenden kommenden Wochen
werden außerdem noch weitere Iris TSM
lenk-
im Frühjahr wird dann auch folgen ein
weiteres Iris TSM Gesamtsystem mit
weiteren Lenkflugkörpern also auch hier
eine weitere wichtige Aufrüstung und
Verstärkung der Luftabwehr in der
Ukraine es wird Materiallieferungen
geben wie immer als Teil eines
Gesamtpakets also auch inklusive
Logistik und Ausbildung und ich will
noch mal sagen wir reden hier am Ende
beim frühjahrspaket über etwas mehr als
eine Milliarde Euro die allein durch das
frühjahrspaket zu Unterstützung der
Ukraine aufgewandt werden insgesamt hat
Deutschland dann mehr als 2,3 Milliarden
Euro 3,3 Milliarden Euro investiert
zeitgerechte
und einsatzorientierte Ausbildung sind
ebenfalls einen Punkt der in besonderer
Weise von Bedeutung ist genauso wie der
der Nachhaltigkeit und der der
Instandhaltung ukrainische Soldaten und
Soldatinnen müssen an den gelieferten
Systemen ausgebildet werden rechtzeitig
ausgebildet werden das stellen wir
sicher bei Marder in dem die waren die
Ausbildung in den nächsten 14 Tagen
denke ich wird beginnen können das heißt
die ukrainischen Kräfte müssen so
ausgebildet sein auf dem zeitlichen
Ablauf dass diese bei Lieferung der
Waffensysteme dann auch unmittelbar
einsatzbereit sind
die Ausbildung am Schützenpanzer Marder
und am Patrick System beginnen bereits
wie ich gerade sagte in den letzten
Tagen des Januars
weitere Unterstützungsleistungen sind in
Vorbereitung
und sind sie aber nicht hier vermutlich
um all das zu hören
und in der Tat haben wir auch über die
Lieferung von Mücke die mögliche
Lieferung von Leopard Panzern natürlich
gesprochen
und zum einen muss ich feststellen ganz
eindeutig es gibt kein einheitliches
Meinungsbild
der Eindruck der gelegentlich entstanden
ist es gebe eine geschlossene Koalition
und deutschland stehe im Weg dieser
Eindruck ist falsch
es gibt viele alliierte viele Verbündete
die sagen wir teilen die Auffassung die
ich heute nicht auch noch mal dargelegt
habe es gibt gute Gründe für die
Lieferung des gute Gründe dagegen
und angesichts der Gesamtsituation eines
Krieges der jetzt schon fast ein Jahr
dauert sind alle Pro und Contras sehr
sorgfältig abzuwägen
und diese Einschätzung wird von vielen
Alliierten das ist sehr deutlich
geworden in den Gesprächen ausdrücklich
geteilt es gibt aber auch natürlich die
anderen
wir können alle heute noch nicht sagen
wann eine Entscheidung und wie die
Entscheidung aussehen wird zu Leopard
Panzer ich jedenfalls nicht sie wissen
warum
ich war aber in meinem beruflichen Leben
einer Erfahrung gemacht wenn man nicht
weiß wann eine Entscheidung kommt und
wie sie aussieht sollte man versuchen
vor der Lage zu sein das spricht dann
auch der Innenminister der langjährige
und vor der Lage zu sein heißt für mich
ich möchte dann wenn einer Entscheidung
fällt ob in einer Woche oder in zwei
oder in einem Tag gehen in der Lage sein
auch schnell handeln zu können für den
Fall einer negativen Entscheidung ist
nicht zu tun für den Fall einer
positiven muss es dann aber schnell
gehen weil es dann darum geht
auszubilden die Leopard Panzer zu
überprüfen und dergleichen mehr deswegen
habe ich heute morgen meinem Haus den
Auftrag erteilt eine Prüfung vorzunehmen
über die Bestände von Leopard Panzern
der verschiedenen Typen sowohl in
unseren eigenen Streitkräften als auch
bei der Industrie
und wir werden dabei insbesondere ins
Auge nehmen die Frage der Kompatibilität
der Systeme auch mit denen unserer
Partner die Verfügbarkeit und die
Stückzahl das alles ist kein prädiodid
das ist schlicht und ergreifend
Vorbereitung auf einen Tag der kommen
möglicherweise kommen mag dann wären wir
sofort handlungsfähig und könnten
innerhalb kürzester Zeit die
Unterstützung liefern wenn denn diese
Entscheidung zwischen der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland und den transatlantischen
Partnern und den NATO-Partnern insgesamt
so getroffen wird das ist jetzt eine
Frage die ich nicht beantworten kann
aber wir sind vorbereitet wir bereiten
uns vor für den Fall der Fälle das
wollte ich sie wissen lassen vielen Dank
darüber haben wir heute nicht gesprochen
ich habe aber ausdrücklich gesagt dass
Deutschland nicht im Wege stehen wird
wenn die anderen Partner genauso agieren
wie wir insbesondere auch was die Frage
angeht möglicherweise schon
vorbereitend auszubilden an den Panzern
das können die Partnerin natürlich gerne
tun und sie können das gleiche tun wie
wir aber eine Frage zu Exportgenehmigung
ist heute noch nicht diskutiert ist
nicht weiter diskutiert worden aber ist
diskutiert worden
möglicherweise auf eigene Faust zu
machen die Drohung wenn man sich als
solche versteht das ist ja auch eine
Positionierung die man damit einnimmt
ich gehe damit relativ gelassen um es
hier heute nicht wiederholt worden
dies ist aktuell leider nicht möglich
ich kann Ihnen keine Antwort geben diese
Entscheidung muss noch getroffen werden
vom Bundeskanzler das ist nicht meine
Aufgabe tut mir leid
wir zögern nicht wir sind einfach nur
vorsichtig
wir wägen das für und wieder ab das geht
nicht darum irgendetwas an
irgendjemanden zu liefern dies ist eine
neue Maßnahme wir müssen hier sehr
vorsichtig sein
wir haben die Pflicht uns dieses Thema
genau anzuschauen und die Folgen
abzuwägen
gehen Sie davon aus dass Polen später
exportieren könnte nun keine
Entscheidungen sind für die Ewigkeit
alten industriepanzer schon wieder
leerzurichten und haben sie ungefähr
einen Überblick wie viele Panzer da sein
könnten und schauen Sie sich auf den
Leopard 1 an also ersten schauen wir uns
alles an zweitens gibt es einen solchen
Auftrag naturgemäß noch nicht weil der
eigentliche Prüfauftrag was haben wir in
welchem Beständen ist erst heute morgen
erteilt worden erst will ich um
entschuldigung ich bin den zweiten Tag
im Amt ich habe es heute morgen den
Auftrag gegeben und warte dann die
Ergebnisse
vorbei
[Musik]
dafür haben wir nicht gesprochen nein
wir kommentieren Sie diese Aussage die
Aussage ist heute hier nicht gefallen
von daher habe ich das auch nicht zu
kommentieren Herr Minister wie kann es
denn sein dass sie erst heute einen
Prüfauftrag vergeben also der
Prüfauftrag die haben wir diese
Diskussion seit Tagen und Wochen da
müsste ja von ihrer Vorgängerin oder von
wem auch immer schon längst ergangen
sein Sie diese prüfen sie erst seit
heute also ich wollte den Vorwurf den
sie da reinlegen den ziehe ich mir nicht
an ich bin wie gesagt seit 24 Stunden im
am viel schneller kann man solche
Entscheidung glaube ich nicht treffen
ich gehe aber davon aus dass das Haus so
wie ich es kenne im Sinne von Truden
planning längst bestimmte Überlegung
angestellt hat oder schon mal in die
Bestände geschaut hat davon gehe ich aus
das ist ein vorsorgendes Haus und darauf
aufbauen ist jetzt der offizielle
Prüfauftrag erteilt worden gab es auch
für ihre Vorgängerin noch keinen
offiziellen Prüfauftrag die Bestände von
Leopard 2 zu prüfen jedenfalls kein
Auftrag den ich kenne ich gehe aber
davon aus intern darüber gesprochen
worden ist
Deutschland vorsichtig ist
haben sie dann Angst dass sie es
negative Folgen haben könnten nein wir
werden so sobald wie möglich diese
Entscheidung treffen wir unterstützen
die Ukraine sehr umfassend und die ist
auch weiterhin
auch darüber gibt es unterschiedliche
Auffassungen es gibt den die Sichtweise
dass die militärische Notwendigkeit
gegeben ist es gibt aber auch die
Sichtweise das ist andere Aspekte dabei
für berücksichtigen gibt ich bin kein
Militärstratege wie Sie sich denken
können aber die Meinung sind darüber
keineswegs einheitlich nichtsdestotrotz
bin ich auch der Auffassung dass eine
weitere Unterstützung der Ukraine in
jeder Hinsicht sinnvoll ist aber wie die
Gestaltung ist in welchem Tempo sie
passiert ist wird unterschiedlich
Bewertung eine Priorität ist heute sehr
klar geworden dass die Luftverteidigung
glauben sie dass Putin auf diese
mögliche Entscheidung mit Vergeltung
reagieren könnte
oder wieso ist Deutschland so zögerlich
nein diesen Eindruck haben wir nicht
Verantwortung gegenüber unserer
Bevölkerung und Europa wir müssen das
Für und Wieder abwägen bevor wir diese
Entscheidung treffen nur darum geht es
und ich bin sicher dass es bald eine
Entscheidung gibt
vielen Dank
lassen Sie also die Ukraine im Stich ich
habe gerade sehr genau erklärt dass
Deutschland weiterhin unterstützen wird
und die sehr gezielt und wir werden dies
tun solange dies nötig ist bis der Krieg
vorbei ist